[Music]
in horny goes wrong news when does it
ever go wrong except for when it's
illegal
broken penises oh my god submitted by
dumpling God everyone's favorite God
I love dumpling a woman is rescued after
attempting of Fifty Shades of Grey sex
stunts which one though which one she
had to be rescued what is that what if
she was like the only one there and
she's like oh my god I think I was gonna
be like this like rescue I pictured like
like paratroopers coming in and [ __ ]
in air lifting her out [ __ ] kick the
windows in abort abort a worn out of a
[ __ ] dungeon she locked herself in or
something Fifty Shades of Grey is not a
how-to book
I never even watched it or read the book
it's not for us okay it's not for a lot
of people no I just thought it ever
heard just remember there's a tampon
scene cuz it's ham did you read it
what's that one I didn't I didn't read
it I don't think I read it but I read
about it how people were like really
felt one way or another that in the
movie they took away this one scene
where he takes out her tampon you
because he thinks it's like a sonnet or
what you know I don't know read the book
but I don't remember that but I read it
before I knew what it was about cuz my
friend just gave me the book and she was
like okay I think you're like this and I
was like okay I get to like Charles
about a world of black and white no I
don't know she didn't even tell me she
was just like I don't even want to tell
you what it's about just read it you're
gonna like it whatever
no I was just like okay and I'm already
like chapter three or I don't remember I
was like wait a second yeah I was on a
road trip and one girl like disappeared
the whole time she was on the beach just
reading the whole time while my other
friend there finger-banging herself like
we were like in like the ocean what
never like what are you doing she's like
nothing we're like given that what is
that and we're like what if we just read
a few sentences really you're reading
sex stuff pretty wild
yeah this is before it like it was there
anything in there you like you're like
what I want to do that um yeah some
stuff I was like sure
anyway so this woman was rescued by
Spanish police so what's happened in
Spain
yeah it's me no it was here but they
just saw I'm gonna be dispatched we need
the Spanish Armada up for this one
without some people got to confuse it
what happened to Mexico oh yeah yeah
thanks for clarifying that's for you got
sort of me not for him you know the
metal scream speak Spanish yep I don't
people get it confused that they also
have Spanish Spanish speaking police
yeah alright so she was trying to
recreate the scene which I also don't
remember but anyway she bound her arms
to the steering wheel of her car it's
amazing and she by herself expiated
herself wait how I don't know this woman
very first and then she did this she put
duct tape around her neck
she ended up she she did the the
steering wheel to the arms to the thing
with cable type that's what she did she
used cable types so now parents can't be
like Oh videogames and all this stuff is
influencing are you
it's like Shades of Grey is doing good
that's a great point we was in the book
I know you don't remember this but in
the book was is done with a partner or
was it done sure I mean that leaves you
by yourself now well cutter I ret no
yeah she was alone in this when I was
you're gonna get rescued where does the
sexual pleasure part come right because
all I hear is torture right now that she
liked is she like okay I'm gonna tie
myself up oh that's really hot she said
oh wow I'll [ __ ] put a put a gag in -
oh yeah up to the neck yeah and she's
like myself she's like wait how do I
wait how do I come oh no no I can't come
no no right she was riding a sybian in
her car there you go what everyone knows
what a saving is tip do all pretend to
be innocent if you're not innocent am I
have you never heard that word I know
you talked about on the show 20 million
times yeah it's a [ __ ] machine it's like
a chair machine yeah I know I've seen
those but I don't know what they were
called Artie well how do you spell that
syb SIDBI I it's Armenian word oh
they're made in Siberia like oh [ __ ]
crazy for research nothing it's so wrong
Oh anyway she parked her car in a
parking lot of a beach a very popular
beach area that's romantic
yeah so then a witness approached her
car oh come on she saw that she was like
all tied up and she was bleeding from
her arms Oh driver seat by the way which
I mean obviously cause it's doing wheel
but still it's kind of funny that she
chose the front of the card to do all
this so um the cops went and then they
finally released her and they were like
what happened cuz people thought this is
a kidnapping yeah yeah um or something
else crazy [ __ ] I got horny she told
that quarter I wanted to recreate a
scene from Fifty Shades of Grey but it
got out of hand
I don't have a partner and I am alone Oh
sounds like an invitation did anyone go
I'm down like hey I'm a police officer
you're in trouble and then she's like oh
I am anything no I'm trying to kind of
I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay I see she was taken to the hospital
to be treated for the cuts and then the
effects of the restricted breathing good
for her though I mean she [ __ ] had a
passion she pursued it you know she just
ended up torturing herself oh yeah but
she could have been like he's someone
tried to kidnap me and try to like say
face but she was honest
that's true I was witness said that
though there was this person I was
camping on the beach and they said they
watch the whole thing you didn't give up
[ __ ] no like this [ __ ] is crazy
well they probably courteously yeah so
then they were saying that the woman was
probably really desperate to be free
because they heard a car horn sound for
about two hours
I was wondering what that was I thought
it was a bunch of pranksters for two
hours a horn if she was all tied up did
she use her is that why she was choking
there's some horns are buttons to the
city on three oh yeah oh this is in
Europe yeah Spain Spain
police I throw him off because I said we
got the Spanish Armada that's all right
think about the beach enemy that I got
transported to Venice
oh it's Jill's fault yes California
California yeah not even not even Italy
they she was repeatedly like banging her
head that's nobody they saw the whole
thing they're like oh no wonder she was
in trouble
Oh crazy lady this whole town sounds a
little the moral to the story is how
European's I'm deuce yeah if you're a
Chinese people just walk by don't do
[ __ ]
Spain good luck it's gonna be you
knocking on the horn for two hours no
idea you should they're not supposed to
do and then they don't do [ __ ] that
they're supposed to yeah they're all
kinds of messed up well there's a weird
thing because like um in America I don't
know 30 years ago or some [ __ ] some lady
was outside getting like murdered yes
buddy right yeah exactly
and no one did it nobody did anything
like 30 people all were all hurt it was
a bystander effect exactly thought
someone else would do it it's just but
hey everyone heard her get murdered
oh no good the whole apartment had
window open in the alleyway right here
she was to to move on to apartments and
there was he heard the screaming and it
took a while for her to die in the East
Coast or something yeah yeah and the
theory is if it was just a single person
watching that single person would have
done something because it's like the
responsibility human behaviors I'm in
Europe it's like that's somebody else
would do it
yeah I do got all the time to I'm like
who's closer he's closer is he is he
brave all right if I'm the closest I'm
life then you walk further yeah
there's 30 people watching something
they're like nose goes this goes oh damn
damn but yeah so I don't know why this
woman decided to use cable ties though I
don't even know what cable ties are no
they sit tight yeah zip ties yeah
that venturous maybe that's what it was
it said in the book which was like ooh
that's hot so it's doing exactly so I'm
like hot what was her exit plan she
probably never used them
it was thinking with her badge very
awful waterboarding and torture a lot of
people a lot of people yeah that's weird
breath play they call it right I like to
play breath play to go what is that
what's that it's like there's guys
that's like hang themselves exact
Association it's like what killed uh
what's his name
I saw the character Carradine Carradine
oh really that's how he died yeah that's
bill and Kill Bill Joe bill he died that
way no [ __ ] caught breath play where
it's like if I hold my breath and jerk
off or whatever it heightens things you
know what I Slavic movie that Robin
Williams was the dad the movies that's
called World's Greatest Dad or some [ __ ]
yeah and his son died from doing that
and then when I heard that he killed
himself with doing that I was thinking
like what if you were doing that well
Robin Williams the way that he died
though I never I read in the report like
he was pushing down enough to kill him
Lana I am yeah
he made us so happy but he was satisfied
no bro sing you like Dan was crazy he
was in a movie that did greatest idea
and then that happened that wind was
doing it just for pleasure but then he
accidentally almost killed himself
no he his son actually killed him his
son does that but to protect his son's
legacy you're like his name and [ __ ] so
that people don't think he's a weirdo or
whatever his dad lies and says that his
son like killed himself and he writes a
suicide letter because his dad's an
author the letter becomes like really
popular and so his dad starts getting
success for me what's that story it's a
really good good movie you make a
tragedy into a benefit that's Bob that's
being positive Bobcat Goldthwait has
like some of the best hooks for movies
I know that's kind of morbid yeah
[Music]